do you mind good
both of you can get the fair share of
questions have anything understood
all good good you can shake hands if you
want that's all right
all right sure uh so using the restroom
oh yeah you can actually go inside your
dressing room
and you have been mocking him all night
yeah
yeah that's right
[Applause]
now he now just because your boy was
smashed
to use khabib's words
it doesn't mean now that you're going to
give me a
usually we would we would explain this
in terms of
one more time one more time thank you
one more time
one more time okay okay just one
question
try to keep it to one we're trying to
get as much
three three is one
after 20 years of researching islam you
come with this
okay you would probably agree with me
let's be honest look at his face
everyone ladies and gentlemen
take a look at his face yes anyways i've
got
a few minutes left let me resize some
quran because i've done with this guy
[Applause]
allah
do you my good hi good hi good hi good
dude
so this hate preaching christian thinks
that
biting or eating a paper that's got
arabic written on
ink in ink is somehow going to affect us
okay anyways because to dispose the
quran we actually burn it
so you know but you know he just wasted
his time
chewing something and why did he do that
because he got destroyed
by muhammad hijab and that video is
evident to that
now brothers and sisters put this guy
aside this is just little mind issues
two images that you have up there of two
females
the first one on the right is called a
pus and his girlfriend
or wife or husband the uh the female
oppos mrs apost both of them insult the
prophet peace be upon him
now if you guys remember in my video
that i did reaction to adam saleh
um destroying this guy i mentioned the
fact that
the fact in academia is mentioned as
well by scholars non-muslims as well
the fact that in an islamically-run
government the capital punishment for
apostates
exists and we're going to be discussing
treason laws and apostasy laws
academically from muslim and non-muslim
sources and we're going to look into
why it makes so damn sense the capital
punishment for treason and apostasy
makes
so much sense yes
oh boy oh boy i cannot wait to share
this video with you guys
so next time an ex-muslim comes to you
and says
in an islamic iran government is the
capital punishment
yes and here is why it makes so much
sense guys oh
i can't wait i can't wait oh boy oh boy
boy you're finished